[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSE MOSTIPAK: So what
do you think should we do?
Let's make a quick little app.
This isn't going
to do much for us.
Right?
We just have our blank app.
But what do you think,
like an input and a button?
I think just a plain button
and maybe some text output,
and it'll be like
random dice roll.
OK.
And this is actually
going to lead up
to one of the first
couple weeks when I was
working with Joe on reactivity.
And it's like we're going to get
to this de-duping random dice
rolls.
What?
Yeah.
OK.
So we're going back
to the good old days.
Yeah.
All right.
Got an action button, perfect.
And then the text
output, you're thinking?
Like verbatim
text output, maybe.
OK.
Just to have it
look code-like.
And then we'll add a
label to the button.
Oh, yeah.
Roll dice or something.
Dice?
All right.
Are we going to
do more than one?
Is it singular?
Wouldn't it be roll the die?
Ah, it just sounds so weird.
It does.
So again, we're going to skip
over making this beautiful
and go straight into
the programming logic.
Absolutely.
I like how you understand me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
So this is a super fun game.
It's going to roll the
dice, and it's going
to give us some kind of output.
And then we're going to work
in different ways to do this.
OK.
So traditionally, in
our server function,
we would want some kind of
like output, codelike_text.
And then how do you
want to approach this?
What do you want to do?
Let's do renderText
and say dice of diceval,
like a reactive, which
is called "diceval."
Oh, OK.
So you're saying "diceval"?
Yep.
And then let's make diceval
as a reactive outside of 14.
Yeah.
Somewhere before.
So we've got our
reactive value,
so this is the value
of our dice, a.k.a.
single die.
It's fine.
Mm-hmm.
And then that itself is
diceval, open, close, in 17?
Mm-hmm.
And 14, we can set
up a reactive val.
We could probably shorten
it to just a reactive.
OK.
That listens to it.
Yeah, has a curly
bracket on the inside,
and it listens to what
input dollar, button, 0, 1.
Yes.
So input.
Oh, OK.
Wait.
I screwed up my formatting.
Sorry.
Oh.
Right?
No.
Isn't it?
It can be multi-line.
I like multi-line.
Yeah.
Input color.
OK.
Button 1.
Button 01.
There we go.
So that's what
we're listening to.
We're listening to
it, but the actual thing
that we're doing, after line
15, inside the curly bracket.
Because just a reactive.
Oh, sorry.
We're doing eventReactive.
Right? eventReactive.
We listen to the button.
Right?
Yeah.
OK.
So we're making this an event--
My bad.
Yeah, my bad.
That's OK.
You were talking
about a reactive.
My brain is thinking
about an eventReactive.
And between the two of us, we
had just an absolute clash.
Something between us.
Yeah.
It was good.
Reactivity is not necessarily
the most intuitive thing
to work on.
All right.
Separating--
Yeah.
Great.
So that's good.
And then comma, curly, and we'll
do random diceval or something
like that.
OK.
We can either just
do the logic here,
or we can make the
function somewhere else.
And are you just thinking
of sample 1 through 6?
Yeah.
And then we can get rid
of the assignment and just
say sample 1 to 6, 1.
Oh.
Yeah.
Perfect.
And let's get rid
of the curleys right
where your cursor's at,
because it's restoring it
to the name diceval.
So diceval, open, close on
14, so you get open, close.
Great.
OK.
Yes.
Whoo.
Reactivity pre-coffee.
[LAUGHING] So
this should work.
Let's find out.
It's an event here.
All right.
So when we click roll
dice, theoretically
what should happen is we should
get a printout of a number.
Ta-da.
There we go.
I think we're getting
all the numbers.
Beautiful.
All right.
We've rolled our dice.
We get our number.
Let's go to Vegas.
Absolutely.
Yes, so this works.
Can we do, after line 9, do
like placeholder is true?
Yes.
And so that's just going
to be when we restart up?
Comma.
Listen, first of all--
Great.
So there's just
at least the box.
Yeah.
So as a user, I'm expecting
something to show up there.
I'm not just looking like, what
happens when I push the button?
Theoretically, this
is a visual cue
that something
will pop out there.
See, I do like a
little bit of UI.
[CHUCKLING]
Little bit.
Yeah, let's not go
overboard today.
Yeah.
Let's not push it.
OK.
All right.
So things work.
This is awesome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So let's try to rewrite
eventReactive without saying
"eventReactive."
OK.
Like how could we do this?
And let's not use
the newer bind event.
Let's actually break it
down to the primitives
of what's happening.
We are essentially
saying diceval,
and we want to do this
without an eventReactive.
So basically, we're
saying, what happens
when we run eventReactive?
Because eventReactive
is like a wrapper
function for some
other things that
are happening under the hood.
And if I remember
correctly, it's
not a reactive and an isolate.
Is it?
It is.
Yeah, it is.
OK.
So let's see.
So diceval, is it reactive?
Is that action--
Go ahead.
Let's actually go
back to our old app
and update it just a little bit.
OK.
So that we can get
some more reactiveness
that the isolate will show off.
Perfect.
So let's add in,
after the action button,
like a slider or
a numeric input.
That'll tell us how many
dice we're going to roll
or what's the highest
number on the dice.
Oh, OK.
I like the highest
number because then--
Yeah.
Let's see, select, max.
Great.
Two of the dice?
Die.
And then we'll need like a
min-max and selected in value.
Yeah.
Min is 1.
Min will be 1.
Max will equal-- ooh.
So max, I'm trying
to think of-- this
is like what the
person is-- oh, no.
Never mind.
We're setting up our input.
So what is it?
Is it 20-sided die?
Yeah.
Is that the highest we can go?
In that 20, yeah.
That 20.
It's step.
Or no.
Is it step or by?
Step?
Step is one.
Yeah, value is 6.
Let's just start with
the default small dice.
Great.
And then we can listen to
that in our sample down in 26.
So sample will be--
Can I do 1 to input--
I think sample.int.
Is that something?
Ooh.
But it's the same
thing, same concept
as where you're heading.
Sample.int.
It is, yes.
Of n, right?
So up to n.
OK.
So instead of this, I'm just
going to comment it out,
so we can see what
we're working with.
So you're saying sample.int.
Let's see. n is a positive
the number of items
to choose from, so this
would be our input?
Yep.
OK.
No, wait.
Yeah.
Yep.
Let is an input here.
And then it's a descriptive
name, but it's long.
All right.
So that is the number
that they've selected.
And then--
And size is one.
Yes.
Giving the number,
so size will be one.
Great.
Is there anything else?
Yeah.
There, I think we're good.
So that should be equivalent.
You could do 1, colon, input,
dollar, select max number.
That works fine as well.
OK.
So you're saying
here we could have
rewritten this as sample
1, 2, input, select.
Yes.
OK.
So if we were looking
for something-- yeah.
We'll keep that there if people
want to see it, so great.
So this should--
OK.
So everything runs.
Let's say, instead
of 6 and we do
expect it-- this is a bug we
talked about in our last video.
So we expect that.
You can override it.
Then we'll go roll the dice.
So it is more than
6, which is good.
That, at least as an
initial kind of unit test,
says to me, great, it's working.
Nothing is throwing
up a red flag.
I suppose there are edge
cases we could still
work on, et cetera.
But this isn't a testing video.
Yeah.
[LAUGHING] Now, it looks good.
Cool.
All right.
So now, we have
this eventReactive
and it listens to a button.
And on the button
click, we sample
a number for a new dice roll.
Perfect.
Yeah.
The end result is diceval is
a reactive, which we can then
read later for the renderText.
Yeah.
OK.
Got it up here.
Now, it's here.
Great.
I love it.
So let's go down the
route of deconstructing back
to the primitives of just
reactive and isolate.
OK.
And observe if
we need it, but I
don't think so in this answer.
OK.
So we're going to
take this right here,
everything that I've
just commented out,
and we're going to break it up
into a reactive and an isolate.
Yes.
OK.
So we're going to call
it the same thing.
And then when I'm
thinking about a reactive
and an isolate, which
one comes first?
Does it matter?
Can I do both?
Can I switch them?
How would I approach this
if I'm thinking about--
So the answer that you're
getting back is a reactive,
and isolates occur in
the reactive expression.
So isolate needs to
be inside the curleys.
OK.
So if I am getting
ready to basically write
my own eventReactive, this
would be my starting place.
That's pretty good, yep.
OK.
So isolate is
inside my reactive,
so I need to think
about what I'm isolating
and what I want to be reactive.
And we're talking
about reactive.
We're talking about responding
to changes in the UI.
Correct.
OK.
So let me think about this.
So what we had here,
so there's the button.
And I'm guessing we want to
isolate the button click.
OK.
We can render it out.
I feel like I just
walked into a trap.
Slightly.
Yes.
OK.
And then how are we handling 26?
26.
OK.
So-- oh.
Wait a minute.
I would like to revise my
answer, because what I want
is I want to isolate
my sample.int.
I want to basically say,
once we have this value,
then pass it to a reactive.
OK.
Can I change it?
Yeah.
Absolutely.
I mean, I know I can, but if
there's a lesson to be learned.
Nah.
You're seeing what's
going to happen.
All right.
So we've handled 26.
Now, how do we handle 23?
Yeah.
So would I put that in here?
So input?
So that would be very
similar code to eventReactive.
Yeah.
But reactive only has one
expression that it can take.
Oh, OK.
Got it.
So reactive, we put the curleys
so that we can do multi-line.
Yep.
And then does it-- oh, OK.
So input.
I'm not sure that this--
this isn't quite right.
I feel like--
So the comma is not
necessary, because it's
an expression from 28 to 31.
And so input button
will trigger reactivity,
but then we will isolate 30.
And so we will use the
value for select max number,
but we will not resample
if the max number changes.
Oh.
This is the answer.
This is great.
OK.
Let's give it a shot
and see if it works.
I was like, wait,
what did I do wrong?
This makes sense to me.
No.
Everything's spot on.
All right.
So we have our
initial value of 6.
Oh, it did roll
for us, so that's
one thing that's going on.
OK.
We can adjust that afterwards.
That's a cool change.
Yeah.
That was unexpected.
So, well, I mean, I guess
some of you expected it.
I didn't.
[CHUCKLING]
And then let's see if
we can get this guy--
we said we could go up to 20.
Great.
We're rolling about
20-- or above 6.
So I feel like our
basic wiring is intact.
The one thing is
that, if I reload,
it automatically rolls for me.
So that is something that we
do need to think a little bit.
Do you have a quick idea
on how to address that?
I'm really hoping it's req.
It is req.
Yes.
Can I just wrap and
put button 1 in req?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Because the default value
for input button 1 is faulty.
It's a 0.
Yeah.
So basically, we're saying
"req" means "require."
And so we're requiring
that button to be pushed.
So because the button
hasn't been pushed,
nothing is rolling.
Now, we can make our changes.
And then when we push the
button, we get a value.
Yay.
Awesome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
So we've taken eventReactive.
We've broken it down.
Now, which direction
do you want to go?
Let's go to the bindEvent.
So we'll going to
the other extreme
and be like, how can we rewrite
eventReactive to just use
bindEvent and reactive?
OK.
So I don't think I've used
bindEvent at all, so I'm really
looking forward to this.
So where do we start?
How do I start thinking
about bindEvent?
So let's look at
the eventReactive,
just because it's very explicit
as to what's happening.
OK.
So eventReactive
has two situations.
It has a I listen
to this situation
and then I perform that
as another expression.
And so the perform that
returns a reactive,
so let's just make a reactive
where we sample the int.
OK.
So we're talking about reactive.
Oh, my goodness.
Sample.int.
Put select max number
and size equals 1.
OK.
So we've got that reactive.
Awesome.
And let's run this app
just to see what it does.
Love it.
OK.
So it works once.
Right?
So when I read out
the app, it rolls.
But the app is rolling for me.
And no matter how many
times I click the button,
it will not reroll.
But if you change the
max dice number, it will.
All right.
So it's basically made
my button useless.
It's like a redundant button,
because all I have to do
is change the number
and I get a reroll.
So we're short-circuiting
something in here.
Yes.
So we want to listen
to the button click,
and so we're going to bind to
the event of the button click.
OK.
And here's where I get to--
I stopped mid-sentence,
but I was like, I
get to do a pipable function.
[CHUCKLING] I could do things.
Yeah.
I get to do--
and then I'm just
going to trail off.
All right.
So I love the way
that you explain this.
Right?
We're going to do the
sampling, but we're
going to bind it to this
clicking of the button.
So if I run this, I'm
anticipating this will be fine.
This will say 6, and
this will be blank.
Let's hope.
[LAUGHING]
Oh.
We forgot to load our--
Yeah.
Should we go native pipe?
Are you on the latest?
Oh, I have never
used it, so let's do
both to show that
they're equivalent.
I'm so scared.
I've never done this.
Because this should
work, theoretically.
Yes.
Let me stop my app
just because it crashed.
So look at that.
All right.
So roll the dice, it works.
If I change it, it's
not changing on its own.
It requires that.
That's great.
So for everyone at home,
that is the base R pipe.
You can definitely use that.
If we want to use our
more tiny versatile pipe,
we could do library magrittr.
And then you can swap
out this guy for this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
These are all equivalent.
Right?
So this right here is
where we broke down
into the primitive functions
to get our dice roll.
And then this is
using eventReactive,
which accomplishes
the same thing
but people might be
more familiar with.
And then this uses bindEvent.
So bindEvent is newer, new-ish.
I mean, in the history
of Shiny, it's new.
Are there situations where I
don't want to use bindEvent
or where bindEvent
wouldn't be appropriate?
Or is it just kind
of always there
as a good substitute or
drop-in for my eventReactive
and my observeEvent?
It's a good substitute.
I'd say it's like
the new school way.
Because rather than having
more and more arguments,
you can just have more
and more decorators,
these extra functions.
Cool.
So this is like the
end of this idea.
I love it.
But I would love to go down
the route of, how can we make
a function of de-duping?
And it might go
towards closures.
It may not.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Do you want to get
rid of these guys?
Yeah, we could
get rid of those.
And the idea is that I
think we'll start the--
and we can talk
about this, but I
want to start the
random dice roll at 3.
The max, max height is 3.
And then that way, it's like
I want a random number that
isn't--
so no, that one is fine.
We can keep it there,
but put the value at 3.
Oh, OK.
And the goal is, when you
roll the dice, you never
get the same number
that you had before.
That's a requirement.
Oh, OK.
So to deconstruct this a
little bit, when I run sample,
I can set replace equals
true or replace equals false.
Right?
If I'm just running sample.
But even though I'm doing a
version of flavor of sample
here, even if I said
replace equals false,
because it's reactive,
that behavior
is going to be overridden.
Yeah.
Reactive will always
return a new--
it'll send down saying please--
I can't think of the word.
Brain fart.
It's like a fresh
start for sample.int.
Yeah, every single time.
Yeah.
So even if I do--
let's see if we can--
So replace won't matter,
because it's size 1.
Oh, yeah.
But you could call sample.int
of 2 of size 1 in the console.
And it will come
with the same answer
multiple times, possibly.
We do sample.int input.
Oh, no.
There's no input.
Sample.int.
Just like 2.
2.
And then we said size equals 1?
Mm-hmm.
Int's OK.
We get 2.
Great.
And we do it again,
we get 2 again.
And the reactivity
would actually
say that that's a new value
and it would redraw it again.
And that's fine.
And now, it finally goes to one.
Yeah.
So the goal for me is to more,
what if we had a de-duper that
said, every time you
click the button--
Don't use any number
that you've already seen.
Or at least not the prior one.
OK.
So we're saying you
can never roll--
OK.
So this is a great
clarification.
We're saying you can't reroll
the number that you just ran.
Yes.
So we just have
to look back one.
Yeah.
OK.
Yep.
Exactly.
OK.
So I thought it
was like, OK, if we
have a six-sided die, once
we roll the number, it's out.
And I think my approach
to that, I was like,
oh, OK, we'll just store
those numbers somewhere.
But now, we're doing
something a little different.
I'm really excited to see
how you would approach this.
Let's do this.
So we're just
saying, if we roll 2,
we can roll any
number that isn't 2.
Yes.
OK.
So maybe we should bump
our min to 2 on the numeric,
because a min of 1
wouldn't make sense.
We'd get forever true.
That's true.
Oh, look at you, thinking
of edge cases right out
of the box.
Yeah.
All right.
Forever.
Awesome.
OK.
Cool.
So do you have any crazy ideas
on how this might happen?
So kind of what
I'm thinking of
is we need some way to store
the number that we just rolled.
Great.
Right?
R needs some way to kind
of catch that number.
So I'm thinking it
almost needs to be
like this temporary
assignment of--
We can make it a reactive one.
Because any time we're
doing a value that's
according to user
actions, typically
it's a reactive or a
reactive val in this case.
OK.
So if you're doing a variable,
it's now a reactive val.
Yeah.
So last roll exists.
And so now, I'm thinking there's
a timing component to this
that is really interesting.
Because if I just do
reactive val, diceval,
those will be the same
every time I do them.
So I need to
stagger in some way.
So for example, I
think this will work,
because I haven't
refreshed my code.
Right?
So I've rolled a 3.
Now, I want to store
3 and remove it
from my possible rolls.
Fair.
Let's try to go through this
a little bit more explicit,
but we could get
smart with it later.
Yes.
Let's brute force
it, then clean it up.
Perfect.
So 25.
Yeah.
Inside 25, you
were saying you want
to know your previous value.
Mm-hmm.
And so let's retrieve
like current roll
or prev roll or
something like that.
OK.
So I have last roll.
And then would I set this
equal to current roll?
That's like new roll.
OK.
I like that better.
And then so this is our new one.
And then we would be like,
while new roll double equals
last roll.
Oh, OK.
So while new roll--
yeah.
So while our new roll--
sorry, hang on.
New roll is equivalent
to last roll.
We want to keep rolling.
Last roll, open, close.
Because it's a reactive val.
Reactive.
This is such a great
example of reactivity.
I mean, I know you know that.
Oh, this one, let me know that
you can really bank on rules.
And it was really neat.
Yeah.
Right?
So we're just going to reroll
until they're not equal.
Yep.
So on 28, we'll need to
update your new roll value.
Oh, that's right.
While new roll is
equivalent to last roll.
Yeah.
So then new roll.
Sampling.
And then at the end of
the reactive expression,
we want to return
the new roll values.
So we'll say return--
or not return but just new
roll at the end, because it's
the last value being--
Yes.
This also gets me all the time.
Yeah.
Yes.
I think it actually
works when you say return.
It does, but we don't need to.
We don't need to.
Yes.
We could print.
We could message.
We could do all kinds
of things there,
but we should be
fine with just this.
So the default dice roll is
3, so there's a high probability
that you would get
the same number.
So if we click it five,
six times, the goal
is to always see a new number.
All right.
So reloaded the app.
Let's see what happens.
Crash and burn.
So we need to maybe, say,
set something for last roll.
Because what's happening
is it's saying like,
while the new int equals null
is what's happening on 27.
So let's just--
Yeah.
--default it to what?
0?
Well, do we want
to default it to 0?
Well, 0 is good.
I was going to say let
it roll, but I like 0
better because 0 is not
actually within our realm
of possibility.
It's like not in
our numbers set,
and it's much simpler
than rerolling.
Yes.
I like your approach better.
You could also do like if not
null, last roll, then do stuff.
Yeah.
But this will be faster.
I mean, marginally faster.
But we're not writing a big--
this is much clearer, though
with some abstraction.
All right.
So when we roll the
dice, we should never
get the same number twice.
Aw, made it rhyme.
Oh, we will.
Oh, no.
No!
What is happening?
This logically
makes sense to me.
It does.
But we're missing
the final step.
So now that we have a new
roll, we need to do what?
We need to replace
the last roll.
There we go.
So let's make a new reactivity,
because that logic is solid.
So let's keep it there.
OK.
And this is a side
effect, because we don't
care about the actual answer.
So instead of a reactive,
we're going to do a what?
For side effects.
Oh, I'm sorry.
observeEvent.
Yes, observeEvent.
But we just learned
about bindEvent,
so let's try to write this
as an observe with bindEvent.
OK.
Oh.
So instead of observeEvent,
we're going to--
Barret, look at you, just
tying everything together.
Barret had the master plan.
I'm literally
along for the ride.
[LAUGHING] All right.
So do we want to call
this updated last roll?
But we don't need the
answer, so it's just
going to be a plain observe.
Oh, that's right.
Right.
You don't have to assign
your observers, basically.
Long and short of it.
I still try, though.
All right.
So we are going to observe--
would it be input button 1?
Nah.
I think we can just
observe the dice roll.
OK.
So new roll or last roll?
Well, let's go ahead
and pipe to the bindEvent,
because then we can talk
about the two situations.
So let's take the observe
and then pipe to bindEvent.
All right.
Let's get some
formatting in here.
So what are we wanting to do?
We are wanting to update last
roll when diceval is updated.
All right.
So we basically want to say
last roll equals new roll.
Great.
So let's do that on 36.
That's the action that
we're going to do.
So last roll.
And then inside the
parentheses, we'll
say new roll isn't
accessible from here.
But that's the value of diceval,
so let's capture diceval.
I really wish I had done
diceval with underscore,
but that's OK.
We can switch it.
It's not too much.
All right.
Let's do it real
quick, real quick.
If you're following
along at home,
we've just added an underscore.
Yeah.
So on 36, new roll
does not exist here.
And diceval would be
underscored and executed.
All right.
It doesn't exist.
Would I super assign it?
No.
So we'll just remove it, because
we can't retrieve new roll.
We can only retrieve diceval.
So let's execute diceval,
because diceval right now
is a function.
OK.
But if we execute
it, then we're
retrieving the reactive value.
OK.
Great.
So this will update last roll
with the value of diceval.
So real quick
question, is that
equivalent to saying last roll?
No.
So that's the urge
to do, because we
are very familiar with variables
where we can say like A is 5.
But to update a
reactive val, you
need to submit it
to the function.
OK.
So the update method
is inside last roll.
Yeah.
So I kind of think of reactive
val as a getter and a setter
to get the value.
You don't send anything
to set the value.
You send in something.
OK.
It's overloaded.
I like the idea of an arrow.
Yeah, it doesn't work.
Because this is more
like where we're
passing functions to functions.
This is like a quirk of
R that we can do this.
OK.
Yeah.
So it should work now.
Right?
But we need something in 40.
Oh, shoot.
That's right.
What are we going to bind it to?
Right.
Otherwise, it's just
going to do its thing.
I'm guessing we're just going
to bind it to input button 1.
So it may work, because
we're performing both actions
when input button executes, but
there's a theoretical edge case
of, what if 35 runs before 25?
Right.
Because we have to remember
that Shiny scripts don't
run line 1 to line whatever.
They don't run in order.
They're more like dynamic.
Right?
Yes.
So it may happen.
Yeah.
So if observe runs
first, now we're stuck.
Yeah.
So if 35 were to run before
25, then that would be bad.
Can I bind this to
the diceval function?
Like diceval has to be called?
Yes.
Diceval.
Awesome.
I think this will work.
I'm going to stop it since I
think I crashed it last time.
We'll get a clean start.
OK.
So we expect, when
we hit roll dice,
that we're going to get not 3.
We're going to just get
like new numbers here.
So 1, so I shouldn't see 1.
Got a 2, 3.
All right.
Look at that.
That's so cool.
This is such a
great example, too,
because I was like, oh,
bindEvent would naturally
bind to--
almost what I would think
of as like a physical event.
Like I'm clicking a button or
I'm seeing a physical change,
but I can bind the event
to a function call.
To any reactive value,
any set of reactivity.
OK.
And I think you can have
req statements in there.
Stop.
Just think of it
as, what would we
do in the beginning of
that reactive expression?
You can do lots of logic.
You can hit lots of reactivity.
All right.
OK.
I want to see what
people do with this.
I want to see all
kinds of things.
I want to see what you
can do with bindEvent.
[SOUND EFFECTS PLAYING]